lundi soir une vaste opération de
contrôles du respect des règles du
couvre-feu a été lancé par les autorités
c'est à 18h pile que les forces de
police ont décidé de donner c'est sur
les routes d'ile-de-france des barrages
routiers pour contrôler les
automobilistes et vérifier s'il avait de
bonnes raisons d'être hors de leur
domicile après l'heure du couvre-feu
tous les automobilistes n'ayant pas une
dérogation pour se trouver dehors après
18 heures ont été systématiquement
verbalisées contre on y pense qu'ils ont
fait le travail contre une seule dans sa
main sur 220 pour ma part je te
comprends le massif a créé un bouchon de
près de 400 kilomètres
un vent de discipline qu'au-delà de
nouveaux cas aussi en ville où tous les
commerçants ne respectent pas forcément
les horaires du couvre-feu
pour le restaurateur prise en flagrant
délit ce sera fermeture immédiate et
pour deux semaines les gérants qui tout
comme leurs clients sont considérées
comme hors la loi alors les français
sont-ils indisciplinés et on va voir
juste cette vidéo de cet automobiliste
qui restait 3h03 voilà sur le péruvien
sur le périph trois quarts d'heure sur
le périph n'était bloqué et se fait
verbaliser leurs hôtes refuse de payer
l'amendé regarde
cinq minutes je suis là enfin et c'est
pour ça qu'il y ait 25 minutes et que je
suis fière
en question tout ce jeu
peut-être
un beau la population
[Musique]
voilà alors oui non est ce que vous
trouvez les français indiscipliné gibert
bête vous dites oui oui et quand vous
êtes contrôlés dans votre voiture autour
de 18h dans les zones qu'on a vu c'est à
dire des zones de départ en week-end
c'est pas parce que vous bossez si vous
bossez vous avez une autorisation vous
n'êtes pas verbalisés quand vous êtes
verbaliser c'est que c'est une
hypocrisie
vous partez au dernier moment
tranquillement week-end et vous n'avez
pas le droit à 18 heures on arrête cette
attention de ne pas vous faire
verbaliser pour votre coiffure un tract
à pee wee non mais non enfin moi j'ai
été pris dans un embouteillage au
heureusement je suis en moto mais
l'embouteillage il avait été créé par
les forces de l'ordre ont créé un mais
vraiment pour le coup ils ont fait ce
qu'on appelle un entonnoir
et si j'avais pas été en moto je me
serais retrouvé à la bourse chez vous
n'êtes pas d'accord récupérer de penser
que les français sont disciplinés mais
ils sont plus que discipline et vassy
pouvez pas dire personne ne peut dire
que les français sont pas disciplinés
c'est incroyable on est le pays le plus
discipliné en europe a dit pas non à tel
point que l'on en arrive à ne pas
confiné
parce que parce qu'on compte aussi sur
la discipline des français pas là pas en
voiture à cette heure-là serre on parle
en parle un peu d'eau tu m'as rallongée
de mal oui mais durera d'une maille et
moi je trouve que les français sont
exemplaires on nous a dit que bientôt
noël
il va y avoir une énorme vague on s'est
tenu à carreau on a été pas plus qu'aux
six on n'a même pas fêter noël pareil le
31 août a dit attention il va y avoir
une énorme vague on est exemplaire
globalement à part quelques fait par ci
par là globalement on a été exemplaire
après on nous dit le variant le variant
ce n'est pas notre faute pardon si on a
laissé ouvert les frontières c'est pas
notre faute donc les français n'y sont
pour rien donc je me trouve extrêmement
exemplaire plutôt très très disciplinés
et effectivement là il ya la règle
évidemment couvre feu de 18h mais aussi
l'esprit de la règle est globalement
quand même les policiers quand ils nous
arrêtent ils font preuve de discernement
il essaie de comprendre là je pense que
c'était une opération de com parce que
permanence est sorti il vous de montrer
que voilà on arrêtait et ont verbalisé
gens voilà vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir
mais sinon globalement on est parfait
nicolas pernikoff du tout ils regardent
et disent regardez le vrai exemple c'est
l'angleterre où il y avait encore il ya
huit jours 1700 morts par jour ils ont
confiné les anglais ne bouge pas de chez
eux ils respectent mon épaule et à
l'horizon
le match aujourd'hui j'étais arrivé
aujourd'hui ils sont à 500 600 morts
donc ils sont arrivés à diviser par
trois en une semaine
aujourd'hui on vous dit 18 heures on
vous évitons nous évite un confinement
total
il faut juste respecter ça alors ce week
end je suis d'accord on aurait pu être
un peu plus tolérant parce que c'est le
premier week-end
c'est ce qui avait été fait il ya un an
mais maintenant regarder quotidiennement
à 18 heures les gens il se balade on n'a
pas le choix plus le confinement plus
plus ce sera court et mieux ce sera pour
tous les français sinon on va on va se
retrouver dans un confinement total
oui déjà pour réagir aux images qu'on a
vue d'un point de vue sanitaire je vois
pas l'intérêt de verbaliser quelqu'un
qui est seul dans sa voiture comme
disait là la jeune femme est ensuite
pardon il ya quelque chose d extrêmement
contradictoires cirque on dit que les
gens doivent être chez eux à 18 heures
mais les magasins certains magasins
ferment à 18h pile
donc certes et les gens qui travaillent
nécessaire que les clients peuvent
accéder au magasin jusqu'à 17 ans 50
ohms et leila une attestation non mais
pas les clients les commerçants
oui non mais les clients ils vont dans
les magasins parce que les magasins sont
ouverts donc les gens surtout en région
parisienne et dans les grandes villes
mais nord à rentrer chez eux
donc à ce moment là s'ils voulaient tous
venir sur la 18' figure mettez un
couvre-feu à 16h c'est pour ça qu'ils
habitent à côté des magazines ont leurs
périmètres baisse ses grands magasins
s'il est vrai qu'elle espérait aussi
j'aime là l'équilibré passé la dernière
partie c'est parti et vous parliez du
ral darmanin justement il avait indiqué
avoir donné à la demande du premier
ministre des consignes de fermeté aux
préfets afin de faire appliquer le
couvre-feu
c'est vrai que dès qu'on repasse 18
heures c'est vrai que benjamin la
question est en fait un court vous
libère tous vos points vous dire vous
dit qu'on venait à 18h vous devez chez
vous mais ça c'est la base du couvre-feu
je trouve que des gens a new day sont
pas chez eux ils parlent de leur travail
et effectivement le gouvernement a fait
une opération comme en fermant pff
j'imagine la tête de ceux qui ne sont
pas qu'ils ont qui ont pris une porte
pour aller pour apprécier ceux qui sont
restés 45 milliards dans le dans les
bouchons et à qui on dit vous allez voir
une amende je comprends que les gens
pètent les plombs et je trouve
effectivement que les français
globalement moi je me balade pas mal
dans paris les gens ils ont le masque
franchement je n'ai pas vu de gens se
balader en masse des gens font attention
effectivement à 18 heures aujourd'hui
dans paris
les gens sont pas sont pas rentrés de
leur boulot ça c'est la vérité
maintenant quand on met en place un
couvre-feu il faut mettre en place avec
les jantes ont surveillé
j'ai paille à l'armée mettait d'armes et
le fait en ce sens que les gens le
respectent mais là il n'y a pas de
surveillance alors on va vous montrer
jours et vous montrer aussi une autre
affaire qui a aussi fait beaucoup parler
ces derniers jours plusieurs clients
d'un supermarché ont été verbalisés
et encaisse alors qu'ils arrivaient
régler leur course alors qu'il déteste
18h06 c'est incroyable le gérant du
commerce aurait lui aussi reçu une
amende car son commerce était encore
ouvert un cas qui ne seraient pas
isolées regarder cette image le
gouvernement dit faire confiance aux
français mais il renforce les contrôles
dans les centres commerciaux comme en
ville après le couvre-feu pour ses
clients surpris a dîné hier soir ce sera
135 euros d'amendé mais son corps humain
et pour le restaurateur prise en
flagrant délit ce sera fermeture
immédiate pour deux semaines
si d'ici là le confinement n'est
toujours pas de retour alors une image
ou bien est ce que les français sont
indisciplinés
il faut quand même leur dire la grande
majorité des français est très
discipliné il faut dire bravo à tous les
français enfin si vous avez de la
famille autour de bush pour son voisin
ou sans argent qui habite à 18 heures
ils sont à la maison et c'est très
compliqué parce que beaucoup de parents
qui continuent de travailler même à
distance et crachats ma démission boulot
à 18 ils ramènent les enfants et en fait
c'est déjà trop tard pour aller faire
les courses c'est très dur ce couvre feu
et on sait que c'est dur mais c'est dur
pour éviter le confinement moi j'ai très
confiance dans les français et aussi
pourquoi il faut sanctionner ceux qui
respectent pas parce que les 99% qui
respecte mais ça laisse un goût pas très
agréable quand on voit ce qu'ils
respectent pas alors vous ne mangez de
dire la règle s'applique à toutes et à
tous et puis on fait tout pour qu'elle
dure le moins longtemps cette règle
alors justement on dit la règle s
applique à tous et vous avez vu cette
histoire de restaurants clandestins lui
en parler aux téléspectateurs il ya les
gars les restos rostand clandestins qui
sont ciblés par la police ces derniers
temps vendredi dernier une dizaine de
magistrats ont été verbalisés alors
qu'il mangeait dans un restaurant
clandestins à paris juste en face de la
cour d'appel et à une centaine de mètres
seulement de la préfecture de police ils
ont été contrôlés alors qu'ils étaient
sans masque dans une terrasse abritée à
la vue de tous en train de boire des
flûtes de champagne les manger quelques
assiettes
il aurait tenté de déstabiliser les
policiers qui les ont surpris ils ont
tous écopé de 135 euros d'amendé
qu'est ce que vous en pensez que ça oui
ça c'est honteux je lis très franchement
et déshonorent leurs fonctions la
justice mérite mieux que et en plus
après il son pack liste à dire qu'ils
essaient de dire moi ça peut passer
comme ça et c'est donc franchement je
trouve ça mais pour tous les gens qui
respectent ces privilégiés
et là qui tentent de passer en force je
trouve ça immonde
elle lui révèle alors dans le vaucluse
et un commissaire et un magistrat créent
aussi été surpris dans un restaurant
clandestins c'est vrai que voilà et
qu'est ce que vous en pensez du mit
alors les français sont disciplinés pour
un jeu raisons la première c'est que
cette année on n'a pas vu de grippe pas
gastro entérite macero she has broken
hill sympa de rhinopharyngites ça veut
dire que malgré tout on porte le masque
on se lave les mains et on fait
attention car il voit dans la ville rose
c'est paris virus comme les autres et on
a vu les français faire un million deux
millions de tests par semaine c'est à
dire qu'au moindre symptôme
on va à la pharmacie on va chez le
médecin on fait une télé consultation on
va au laboratoire dont qui sont
volontaires en revanche qu'on peut dire
c'est que s'il faut sanctionner des gens
c'est plutôt les restaurants clandestins
je pense que vous être responsable d'une
propagation du virus et l'épidémie ne
sera pas contrôlable tant qu'on aura ce
genre de rassemblement en revanche dans
les embouteillages sur le périphérique
ce genre d'actions coup de poing ou
venir à 18h05 dans un supermarché
ça va juste embêter les gens et puis
surtout on va pas contrôler l'épidémie
donc il faut peut-être un juste milieu
de la sévérité mais un peu de justice
quand même qu'ils pensent alors vous
pensez tout ce que les français sont
disciplinaire par nicolas pernikoff et
gilles verdez worth qu'en pensent les
téléspectateurs un moment oui très vite
oui à 53%
non à 47% c'est beaucoup plus il sans
respect des gestes barrières on n'aurait
pas vingt mille cas par jour mais cent
mille cent cinquante mille ha ouais
c'était comme au brésil on aurait
peut-être dépassé les 150 millions donc
oui les français sont responsables des
imbéciles y en a partout de toute façon
mais c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas à
cause de ça que l'épidémie flambent
c'est le virus qui est comme ça